OK.
More and more elements of our country are
slowly but very surely inconsistently shutting
down, at least in blue states.
I know red states, some some red state governors
are bragging about going out to crowded restaurants
and going to the beach and stuff.
But in blue states, we're taking this very
seriously.
And the IRS has now announced that the.
Tax deadline for taxes owed will be extended
by 90 days.
Now, I want to be really clear, because some
people are misunderstanding this.
This is the deadline to pay taxes owed not
to file.
And it is only federal states may not be.
Your state may not be doing this.
All right.
You still need to file your taxes by April
15 or file for the extension, which push pushes
to October fifteen.
If you owe money, you get a 90 day extension
on paying the money that you owe.
Then you also need to look at whether your
state is doing the same thing.
California's doing a 60 day extension, so
it's not going to match up exactly with the
federal government.
We've posted a link in the description on
the YouTube video for this story to a document
that is updated for each state.
So Connecticut has extended it until June
15 to pay taxes owed, not to file as far as
we can tell right now.
Indiana did delay filing altogether until
June 1, but you've still got to file your
federal.
Massachusetts is waiving penalties for six
months.
So this is really a big deal.
The limit for what individuals can delay are
payments of up to a million dollars.
For corporations, it's up to 10 million dollars.
There will be no interest in penalties during
the 90 day period.
Now, if you're due a refund, get your taxes
in, because, of course, the sooner you do,
the sooner you get your money.
I believe that I filed my return on March
9th and I'm told my refund should be coming
by March 30th.
That's 21 days.
So it looks like they're on a 20 on a three
week turnaround time on that.
And I you know, but as a business owner, I
estimate my my taxes throughout the year and
make estimated payments.
I know that by overestimating, I'm giving
the government an interest free loan.
It's not drastic, but I prefer to do that.
And no, I'm not going to have to cut a check
at the end of the year.
And I'm expecting a refund in the next twelve
days or so.
Important to understand from a macro economic
perspective, all of this stuff that's being
done is deficit spending.
Everything that's being discussed is deficit
spending.
Notice how very quickly we can't afford it
becomes.
We can't afford not to with even Republicans
like Mitt Romney talking about what is almost
at least a single payment of Andrew Yangs
universal basic income of a thousand dollars.
Now, the counter argument will be, of course,
David, this stuff is temporary versus making
systemic change, which is what Democrats want.
But there's a very simple counter counter
argument, which is, listen, a lot of the things
we're doing now in an emergency are only necessary
because we didn't do the changes systemically.
For example, the panic around restaurant workers
who work on tips now not having money, that
panic would be much smaller if we had a system
in place for paid sick leave, unemployment
that accounted for tips, et cetera.
We now we're talking about we've got to start
sending cash to people.
We've got a deficit spend because we have
no such system.
And in fact, I tweeted yesterday stuff that
we normally Republicans say we can't afford
now we can't afford not to.
And that was exactly the reaction I got from
a lot of people who are thinking short sidedly
to check out some of these responses.
Someone said, quote, There is a difference
of supporting people during a crisis where
a lot of people lose their jobs and the normal
situation where you're responsible for your
own situation.
Another person said to me, temporary relief
is different than long term policy.
Apples and oranges.
But the reality is that if you have policies
that strengthen the economy to get people
out of these precarious employment situations
all the time as a baseline, you soften the
blow of an emergency like this and all the
money you've got to start spending.
One other example, tweet I got someone said
emergency funding is different than perpetual
borrowing.
That's very short sighted, guys, because an
ounce of prevention is really worth a pound
of cure.
If you build in some of these mechanisms all
the time as a baseline, it's much more predictable
than an emergency where you have to start
haphazardly saying, let's send people a thousand,
let's send people three thousand five hundred
per kid, bailouts, a payroll tax cut.
You end up being much more predictable in
your budget when you plan ahead for these
social safety nets.
And you know, anyway, taxes owed being delayed,
restaurants shutting down, schools shutting
down.
And we can expect more of this to continue
until things start to settle down.
And we don't know when that will be.
Understand that right now a lot of this depends
on you and me.
But also, you know, those people in red states
who are partying at the beach.
There are estimates that cases could peak
in 14 days.
There are estimates that this.
Could extend until spring of 2021.
That's an insane range.
All that means is we don't have a clue and
it depends on our actions.
Importantly, by the way, I tweeted out yesterday
and I encourage everybody to look at this.
Sal Khan from Khan Academy.
Brilliant guy, excellent Web site.
He did an analysis of a blog post which explains
how you have to the number of new cases reported
is on a significant delay from the number
of actual new cases.
And he is explaining that actual new cases
will likely start to decline long before the
official numbers reflect it.
He explains why.
Really important.
The simple math underpinnings to understand.
So check that out.
I tweeted it yesterday.
I'm D
Packman
on Twitter.